[Music]
foreign
everyone lots of news to bring you on
the economy this morning not least a
warning of a 60 billion pound black hole
in public finances first we want to
update you though on what's happening in
Ukraine overnight a UK spy Chief has
given his analysis on the war in Ukraine
saying that Russia is in a tight spot
and Ukraine is turning the tide that's
as those reports of more than a dozen
fresh airstrikes in zapparitzia
overnight in a speech to be given today
sir Jeremy Fleming who is the director
of gchq will say this their gains are
being reversed the cost to Russia in
people and Equipment are staggering we
know and Russian commanders on the
ground also know that their supplies and
Munitions are running out Russia's
forces are exhausted the use of
prisoners to reinforce and now the
mobilization of tens of thousands of
inexperienced conscripts speaks of a
desperate situation
yesterday President Putin ordered a wave
of missile strikes in several cities
across Ukraine at least 14 people were
killed and almost a hundred have been
injured president zielinski condemned
Russia's terrorist state
Ukraine cannot be intimidated only
United even more Ukraine cannot be
stopped only convinced even more that
terrorists must be neutralized the
Russian army specifically struck these
blows precisely during the morning Rush
Hour this is a typical terrorist attack
well these are the latest images
reaching us here at Sky Center we know
that the
leader of Ukraine has once again asked
for the support of the British
government pictures that we showed you
first yesterday morning I'm pleased to
say the Deputy Prime Minister is with us
here in the studio good morning to you
thank good morning joining us
um what support can you offer them
well I think we continue the support
that we've been giving and uh the Prime
Minister has was Florence actually
beforehand working in step with our
defense secretary Ben Wallace and at the
time prime minister Boris Johnson and we
continue to do that and we need to make
sure that the West is also resolved to
making sure that Putin must fail and the
people of Ukraine must succeed okay so
is there anything specific that we can
do to help them given these missile
strikes that we have seen over the last
couple of nights well of course some of
these operational matters of the direct
support will be given will be held
discussed confidentially confidentially
with uh both within government but also
with the Ukrainian president and I know
that we have always stepped up to
deliver what we can but this is a time
for other countries to continue the
level of support that they've been
showing and where necessary to escalate
their their level of support directly to
the Ukrainian Armed Forces as we have
done okay this is our first opportunity
to chat since the conference and there
has been a further slump in the polls
how are you going to get back on track
well I'm very conscious that we've set
out a plan for growth there's a whole uh
continuing of different policy uh
improvements to try and help and lock
our growth challenges that we've been
facing and indeed the chancellor
announced yesterday he's brought forward
the medium term fiscal plan for the 31st
of October
to do that recognizing that we wanted to
get on and show how our plans and make
sure people have confidence that they
can get on and start delivering them and
he's decided that we're in a position
where we can bring that forward it's not
because the Market's getting jittery
again not to my knowledge
um I think it's about doing a lot of
work at PACE uh understandably uh but I
think he decided that we're in a good
State and we'll continue to discuss this
across government and indeed with
parliamentary colleagues
um over the few weeks ahead you say in a
good state but the director of The
Institute for fiscal studies is saying
this morning that there's a 60 billion
pound black hole in your figures and
that's either going to be done to sort
it out with a hatchet to public spending
or the equivalent of a Tempe increase in
the basic rate of tax which one well I
think the ifs obviously does its own
modeling the government works with the
bank of England and the obr on these
measures and that's uh What uh treasury
has been working on and doing different
discussions with different departments
but I think the ifs also pointed out if
we don't grow then this problem will get
worse and worse and that's why very
clearly the Prime Minister and
chancellor set out a plan for growth a
lot of that of course was the important
element of giving Assurance to household
and to businesses about what support
they would get on energy costs much of
which is not in the direct control of
people we've already seen an impact in
the reduction of inflation uh forecasts
just from the measures that we've taken
but to consider we've had this
Aftershock of covid we still not quite
yet got the global supply chain going
again and we still have the huge
problems on energy security which is
affecting not just this hasn't been
affecting just this country but of
course also countries right across
Europe and elsewhere in the world but
people should be assured we have the
second lowest debt to GDP ratio and the
g UH 60 billion black hole though um how
are you going to fund it well I'm I'm
just uh flagging that ifs has come up
with its own modeling is it right and
the chance that's uh not for me to say
that's their forecasts uh the chancellor
will be speaking at the end of the month
uh with the medium term fiscal plan okay
but suggestions are that you will have
to find on their figures for now we'll
hear yours as you say by the end of the
month if you don't
um fix these figures with an increase in
basic rate of income tax you'll need to
reduce the budget of every Department
except the NHS and defense by 15 is
there that much fat to get rid of well
I'm just not going to get into
hypotheticals k um the chancellor is
working on that uh with uh as the
aspects obr other departments right now
to go through um but I the government is
united we have to get growth otherwise
uh and that will help us to fund our
public sectors in the future as well
okay um so you're not going to get into
figures we'll just have to wait and see
till the 31st of October as I said the
Market's getting jittery again one
wonders what they might do between now
and then what we do know is that
Santander are saying that they're
setting um just looking at the exact
quote from their boss saying they're
having to set aside more money for
defaults uh because they think that
people are just not going to be able to
afford their mortgages going forward how
do you reassure them otherwise all the
bank of England sets the uh interest
rates for the country and um it's for
their projection to decide they we've
had historically low interest rates for
many years now and of course they're
going through covert there was a lot of
work done when many people either
weren't uh were benefiting from furlough
or indeed were not who had to be helped
with that no I'm just lagging That Was
Then That Was Then historically what the
government did to help people Bank of
England the bank of England sets the
interest rates so it'll be what
responsibility should this government
take or the backing of England sets
interest rates um I'm not aware that any
other commentator once the government to
start setting interest rates again
um and I doubt Santander does as well
but the sorts of policies that we've
shown like our support to both
households and businesses in substantial
energy package building on the 37
billion pounds that we had already
talking about building you're talking
about ditching home targets for
affordable homes why are you doing that
I'm not aware of any of that that isn't
true I'm not that isn't true that
apparently ministers have drawn up plans
to exempt developers from having to
build affordable homes to scrap
Environmental Protections and to allow
people to add extensions without
permission that according to Simon Clark
that's not right I'm not aware of that
uh policy but uh if you want to ask
Simon Clark about policies oh yeah the
Deputy Prime Minister with all due
respect
um well you're just throwing comments at
me okay
um I'm not aware of there's not
something that's been discussed around
I'm not aware of uh specific things like
that no okay how interesting Secretary
of State for health and that's uh I have
come on today to talk about what we're
doing to help tackle the backlogs and
I'm pleased to be announcing a further
10 Community diagnostic Centers to be
opened I'm actually opening one formally
today in London but places in Burnley uh
places in emergency side uh places in
the Isle of Wight will be getting a
diagnostic center because we know
getting on and delivering for patients
is really important and those
Diagnostics are a key part of making
sure whether we know if people need
treatment or not and that is one of the
critical backlogs that we need to get
fixed
um also talking about National Insurance
rise being scrapped today in Parliament
that's at 36 billion pounds over three
years that will be gone how will you
protect the NHS given that that money
was going to be spent on the NHS and
social care well that was going to be in
effect a hypothecated levy that was set
aside uh the Prime Minister said clearly
during her leadership campaign she
didn't think it was right to put up
taxes and so so this will be funded more
generally from General taxation rather
than specific levies so it's the funding
is still there in order to make sure
both social care and health system
particularly that money was intended in
the health system for tackling backlogs
that we spend that and then moving on to
aspects of social care of which we'll be
doing the first down payment this winter
with 500 million pounds to be allocated
across the country nurses balloting to
strike for the first time in 106 years
also relevant to your department what
are you going to do about that well I
understand
um that the ballot is now open uh we
have honored the independent pay review
bodies recommendations on this uh and
that was a higher than many of the other
pay Rises that other public sector
workers are getting and I'm confident
um that uh those uh elements will
continue to
do I say it's uh having respected the
independent pay review body I'm not
anticipating that we're making any
further changes okay so it looks as
though it'll have a strike on your hands
well I think that's a decision for the
nurses who decide how to vote this um
this uh in this next coming month okay I
mean you're sitting here as the Deputy
Prime Minister this morning nurses
threatening to strike for the first time
in 106 years the head of Santander
saying he's having to put extra money
aside because he thinks that people are
going to default on their mortgages The
Institute for fiscal studies saying
there's a 60 billion pound black hole in
your figures
um and you just think the country will
just carry on running as it is well no
we need to change that's why we need a
plan for growth and why we have a plan
and it's well that was set out a few
weeks ago and then the medium-term
fiscal plan is what the chancellor will
be saying at the end of the month so
it's not exactly business as usual
that's why in my role as Secretary State
for Health and Social care we've got
real focus on ABCD the ambulances
backlogs I'm talking about today as well
as some of the things that we'll be
doing in terms of care including the
discharge fund for this winter so we'll
continue to try and make progress in
delivering for patients and indeed
delivering right across the country
including the delivery of the energy
cost package where we are supporting
homes and indeed our businesses you talk
about the ABCD plan which we've heard a
lot about both from you from the Prime
Minister also from Nadeem zahari who
spoke about it too what can we expect on
the Tobacco Control plan
well I'm focused at the moment on the
ABCD there's a whole number of different
prevention strategies which are already
underway and some are being considered
my immediate Focus has been ABCD about
we've created within the NHS local NHS
boards that are referred to as
integrated care system boards Care
Systems which have a board and that's
where I'm intending to put all of our
effort and focus on how we get that
local Health and Social care system
really working together so that's that's
where I'm putting a lot of my focus
right now okay the plan was vital we
were told to help the government realize
its ambition of becoming smoke free by
2030 we heard that from Sajid Javid
reducing number of 15 year olds who
smoke from eight to three percent
reducing smoking adults in England from
15 and a half to 12 reducing inequality
Gap in smoking prevalence end of 2022
was the target has that Target been
scrapped I I'm not aware any Target has
been scrapped um but I'm going to go
ahead then I'm not aware any target has
been scrapped my focus right now is the
ABCD there's quite a lot of prevention
programs already underway and I'll be of
course looking at many more these in
detail there's quite a lot of ambition
that we have uh looking at say at the
Cancer plan again we're going through
that carefully and my expectation is the
prime minister set out is we'll publish
that by the end of the year
um okay my producer's just talking to me
in my ear as I'm talking to you so she
if she could just say me again I think
it's something from the bank of England
bear with me there's a warning I'm being
told from the bank of England
and apparently there's an ongoing route
in the guilts market a material risk in
UK Financial stability thoughts on that
well it's news to me as well and uh I
suggest the Deputy Prime Minister you
have to have views on these things I've
just been sat here for the last 10 15
minutes you're not expecting it uh it's
a matter of dare I say for the
chancellor I'm sure that you can follow
up with the chancellor today uh the bank
is saying that it's going to have to
bolster its emergency Bond uh buying
plan well the bank of England is the
responsible organization uh and uh it's
for them and the chancellor to work
together on this matter it's good to
talk to you as always thank you very
much thank you for joining us let's have
a look at what Ed Conway has been saying
uh with his uh
um latest graphs he's joining us in just
a second this is what he said earlier
just what is causing quartet gonna have
to do to try and sort out the public
finances well we have one answer for the
institute for fiscal studies we've got
their green budget it basically looks at
all of this stuff and here perhaps is
the most important chart it shows you
the national debt so the total amount
that the UK government owes and that has
built up over many many years a lot of
that's due to covid but here's the thing
we're looking through to the Future here
and what you can probably see from this
is that it was more or less flattening
as starting gradually to fall that's
gradually going down in the coming years
but here's what happened in the mini
budget the government basically added a
lot to it so whether it's the energy
price guarantee all of those other
measures reversing those tax increases
you can see that's going up and that's
the thing that markets are concerned
about certainly the ifs is concerned
about it as well and the big question is
how do you bring that down how do you
kind of get that slab down so that you
are bringing the national debt lower
well that costs a lot of money according
to the ifs and City who are looking at
these numbers 62 billion pounds needs to
be removed and where do you get 62
billion pounds from well it's a lot of
money let me just show you for
illustrations some of the things you
could cast or change to get to it but
it's just illustration this stuff is
pretty controversial for instance
operating benefits by earnings so not
raising them in line with inflation it
means a real terms cut for those uh many
of those who are on benefits 13 billion
pounds you can get from that you get
about 14 billion pounds by cutting your
investment spending but here's the thing
investment spending is one of the things
that generates growth and if this
government really is about growth growth
growth that doesn't seem like the
obvious thing to cut or finally you
could cut non-nhs or defense spending
their day-to-day spending that's
basically like austerity but if you cut
it by about 15 then you're talking about
35 billion pounds quite a lot of money
but none of these are very palatable
options the final option the one the
government would most like and everyone
would most like is to get growth the
more growth you have the lower that has
to be but here's the thing even if you
assume there's going to be perhaps 0.25
extra growth that's what city says is
possible you're still talking about 41
billion pounds you're still all talking
about potential Cuts you're still
talking about potential austerity those
are the choices facing quasi-quarters
none of them particularly palatable but
that's where he stands right now
we've been getting fresh data on the
economy this morning uh that those
latest figures that we're just getting
the latest warning from the bank of
England more on that in just a second
first though our business and politics
correspondent Amanda acas is here with
me Amanda figures coming thick and fast
this morning try and dissect it all for
me yeah so the latest stats we've got
from the office National statistics and
the latest quarter number of people in
work so unemployment has fallen again to
a new record low 3.5 percent that's the
lowest it's been since
1974. but interestingly the number of
economically inactive peoples about a
fifth of the population and the number
of people who are off workers of
long-term sickness is now at record high
which is is quite interesting given the
pressures that we're seeing on the NHS
the long waiting lists the number of
people suffering with long covid and so
on now also the other key thing to know
from this is about earnings so in this
we can see that average
um Regular pay fell when adjusting for
inflation by four percent now that's in
real terms
um but that is isn't quite as bad as the
last time when it fell by 4.1 percent
that clearly it really shows you the
struggle people are having trying to
keep up with inflation as the how they
can pay for things with the earnings
that they've got particularly which
politically we know this big debate
that's going on at the moment is whether
or not benefits should be going up in
line with inflation or average earnings
average earnings aren't doing very well
so it's even a bigger Gulf between the
difference that we're seeing if they
went up with a nine with inflation and
then that would obviously cost the
government a lot more money but would
stop a lot more people from falling into
poverty indeed so and these figures we
get uh once a month once a course uh
once a month yes indeed is the average
amount for the previous three months so
fundamentally it shows us we know that a
lot of people are in work there are a
lot of vacancies not quite as many
vacancies as we've been seeing recently
but still really historically record
highs 1.2 million or so across the
entire labor market but the number of
people they're inactive that's going up
as well so we can see that for all the
government is trying to do to get people
into earning you know working more hours
earning more money that clearly isn't
really
um being affected and people's real the
amount of money people are actually
taking home um is going down effectively
and that's what they're feeling in their
pocket okay let's bring in tomorrow
should we she's standing by in Downey
Street for us this morning and tomorrow
expecting
um another cabinet meeting later on but
those latest warnings from the bank of
England we didn't get much response from
the Deputy Prime Minister but it's going
to be alarming isn't it
morning care yes Liz truss is chairing
her first cabinet meeting since a
chaotic Party Conference and very bad
news for the conservatives in the polls
with labor having huge leads in almost
all of them now we expect that expected
this this meeting to be dominated by the
decision over benefits and whether to
raise them by the rate of inflation
which senior figures in cabinet feel the
government should but it's all been put
in perspective today by this overview
from The Institute of fiscal studies
about how the chancellor is going to
balance the books how to fill that black
hole that he created with the mini
budget and they're talking about 60
billion pounds needing to be found over
the coming years if he is to get the
debt falling as a percentage of GDP
which is what he said that he would do
and announce his plan for that coming
forward at the end of the month so where
might the acts fall well Therese coffee
said that will be for the chancellor to
decide we expect that the NHS and
defense budgets would be protected
although of course both are being over
eroded currently by inflation so the
inflation situation makes all of that a
lot more difficult we've just heard from
the bank of England in the last few
moments it's the second tweak to this
big Bond buying operation that they
launched a couple of weeks ago in the
light of the mini budget and we we know
that they're extending the scope of it
essentially after it emerged yesterday
at the borrowing rates are as high as on
the day they intervened so we wait to
see exactly what the impact of all this
is going to be on the market but it is
more Grim news for the chancellor on a
day that he will be facing MPS in the
Commons today for treasury questions and
of course the government is trying to
Ram its legislation through Parliament
to reverse that rise in National
Insurance today so we'll see how much
reaction there is from the conservative
benches on that uh yeah thank you very
much for now tomorrow quick look at the
papers for you you and the eye says
trust faces Showdown with Rebels ahead
of a cabinet meeting later this morning
the Ft says the chancellor in the Bank
of England failed to calm the markets as
interest rates on government bonds rose
again yesterday uh the day death ranged
from the sky is the headline in the mail
referring to what it calls Vladimir
Putin's Blitz on several Ukrainian
cities the guardian reports that
president zielinski is pleading for more
help to combat Russian attacks
joined Now by our security and defense
editor Deborah Haynes and hi Deborah
tell us what the Spy Chief is telling us
and what does that mean both for Russia
and indeed for Ukraine so it's the head
of gchq who's going to be giving a
speech later on today and we had some
excerpts of what he's going to say
released to us and he made some very
Stark comments on the war in Ukraine he
said that Russia is running out of
Munitions and supplies
um that that Russia has already incurred
a staggering in his words cost in terms
of personnel and Equipment lost and then
he also went on to talk about the impact
on the Russian people the fact that they
are fleeing the draft the fact that
prisoners are being deployed on the
battlefield saying that's a mark of
desperation and this all comes at a time
when Russia really has escalated the
conflict with those devastating
airstrikes yesterday in response to
those mysterious blasts on the bridge
linking the Crimean Peninsula with the
Russian Mainland and the the thinking
now is that yes while Western Well
Russian weapons might well be running
out the West is also under strain the
Western weapons are key for Ukrainian
success Russia is not giving up it is
doubling down so while yes maybe Russia
is running out of supplies its forces
are exhausted they're not going away and
that's why you had President zielinski
yesterday speaking to President Biden he
also spoke to our prime minister Liz
truss and he said that his number one
priority is on air defenses the country
desperately needs to be able to better
protect itself and on strengthening its
Armed Forces further so this is a moment
of escalation it's a moment of danger
and clearly the UK spy Chief is is
hoping that Russia is going to run out
of of weapons but it hasn't at the
moment
um these missiles that came in yesterday
with such deaf station hitting
playgrounds and bridges and the like we
had thought that the Russians were very
depleted in the stocks of those but
again we've seen more overnight into
zabaritzia we have and also the
Emergency Services have put the entire
country on alert again today telling
people to stay in shelters not to ignore
Air Raid Sirens it's been going on for
months people you hear the air raid
siren and you often just put it to the
back of your mind because you don't
think a missile is going to Land close
to you but clearly yesterday we saw
they've still got that capability it
also seems they've been planning that
attack for a while it wasn't just some
spontaneous moment in terms of
responding to the bridge that that might
have precipitated it but yes you're
right it clearly shows they haven't run
out of stocks they're also using Iranian
weapons too Iranian Kamikaze drones as
part of their strikes and they've
clearly got the ability to do to do more
and they're saying that they are going
to respond as long as the West continues
to support Ukraine then Russia will
respond that's what the deputy foreign
minister has been saying today okay and
when will we hear this um the speech
from our spy Chief it's going to be at
two o'clock this afternoon lovely or 2
30. okay thank you very much thank you
still to come early afternoon still to
come on the program for you right now
though Labor's Shadow Chief Secretary of
the Treasury will be with me soon after
eight o'clock
we'll be speaking to the former
presenter and model that's Annie
Lancaster and labor MP Carolyn Harris as
they work to tackle the stigma
surrounding the menopause
also speaking to the Ukraine ambassador
to the UK after Russia launched dozens
of airstrikes right across the country
in other news Harry Kane will wear a one
love armband at the World Cup in Qatar
even if it's prohibited or punishable by
FIFA the fa has not yet received
permission from FIFA to wear the armband
which forms part of an
anti-discrimination initiative despite
asking three weeks to go but the team
are determined to have the captain wear
it even if it risks fines let's get more
should we shiman is standing by for us
this morning hello to you Siobhan tell
us more about this
oh I think we might have a problem there
with your microphone can you let's just
see if we can sort that out are you
there
Invasion no we haven't got your mic just
at the moment but we'll sort that out
and come back to you very shortly indeed
do bear with us on that now let's look
at some of today's other headlines for
you now in a forba at Labor Shadow
ministers been deselected from his seat
a first in more than a decade sanitarian
Ally of the former labor leader Jeremy
corbyn was deselected from the ilford
south constituency by local party
members the vote means he won't be
Labor's constituency candidate at the
next general election the former Shadow
transport secretary was sacked from the
job in July after unauthorized broadcast
interviews from a picket line which
started here on this program
nurse accused of murdering seven babies
and attempting to kill 10 others in a
neonatal unit in the contest of Chester
Hospital has been described in court as
a poisoner at work a jury heard that
Lucy letby injected newborns with
insulin air or milk during night shifts
when she knew their parents would not be
present
opening the prosecution case Nick
Johnson Casey told the jury the collapse
and deaths of the 17 children named in
the indictment were not naturally
occurring tragedies they were the work
of the woman in the dock who was the
constant malevolent presence when things
took a turn for the worse sometimes
Lizzie letby tried to kill the same baby
more than once sometimes the baby she
succeeded in killing she did not manage
to kill the first time she tried or even
the second time and in one case even the
third time the 32 year old denies all
the charges against her
new analysis shows that care workers are
more likely to live in poverty than the
average UK worker research from the
health Foundation found that one in five
residential care workers in the UK were
living in poverty before the cost of
living Crisis began
now talking about Harry Kane wearing a
one love armband tell us more
hello good morning Kay well the fa
announced back in September the
intention to allow the England team to
be able to wear these armbands in
support of an anti-discrimination
campaign and also in support of the
lgbtq plus Community because in Qatar
same-sex relationships and promotion of
same-sex relationships are still
criminalized but in order to wear these
armbands fa and the England squad would
need permission from FIFA but as you say
despite asking for this permission more
than three weeks ago FIFA have yet to
respond but Sky News does Now understand
that the England squad are prepared to
wear the armbands in support and in
solidarity even if it means facing a
fine or other forms of punishment now
the England manager Gareth Southgate has
spoken a few weeks ago about the issue
and he said that there's not a lot more
that the players in particular can do
other than talk about those issues and
put them on the table because in the end
we're asking for change in a country we
are respectful of has made progress but
don't have any control over talking
about the issues and raising the issues
and putting them on the table it's a
vehicle that people involved in sport
we've used in the past and it is what we
are trying to do this time our
delegation from the group are meeting
with FIFA in Zurich tomorrow to discuss
the issue they'll also be asking for an
update on a helpline and compensation
scheme for migrant workers that have
been working on the facilities for the
World Cup in Qatar because human rights
Charities have raised the fact that some
that there are some issues in the way
that migrant workers have been treated
Sky News has asked FIFA and the fa for
comment
okay for no thank you
check these pictures out three fishermen
whose boat capsized in the Gulf of
Mexico had a lucky Escape when they were
rescued after 24 hours stranded in shark
infested waters though they are being
rescued uh the U.S Coast Guard said they
were fending off sharks with their bare
hands when their helicopter arrived the
men are being treated in hospital for
shark bites
my goodness a picture of what remains of
one of the fishermen's life jackets
after that shark attack oh goodness
hello again everybody welcome back to
the breakfast show here on Sky News
Tuesday Morning speaking to the program
this morning the Deputy Prime Minister
has said people should be assured about
the state of the economy despite a fresh
warning of a 60 billion pound black hole
in the public finances Therese coffee
told me that we needn't be too worried
about the way the economy is looking
we're in a good State and we'll continue
to discuss this across government and
indeed with parliamentary colleagues
over the few weeks ahead you say in a
good state but the director of The
Institute for fiscal studies is saying
this morning that there's a 60 billion
pound black hole in your figures well I
think the ifs obviously does its own
modeling that other government works
with the bank of England and the obr on
these measures and that's what treasury
has been working on and doing different
discussions with different departments
but I think the ifs also pointed out if
we don't grow then this problem will get
worse and worse and that's why very
clearly the Prime Minister and
chancellor set out a plan for growth
let's bring him more now on the war in
Ukraine and president zielinski has
vowed to strengthen the country's Armed
Forces following major Russian
airstrikes which killed at least 14
people Russia launched attacks on cities
from leviv in the west to kharkiv in the
East the strikes on the Ukrainian
Capital Kiev and shevchenko District
were the most intense killing at least
eight people and injuring dozens of
others missiles also targeted the
Central City of denipro where our
special correspondent Alex Crawford
begins her report
commuters were on their way to work
when the bombs started this was Terror
and Mayhem reaching fresh Heights in
Ukraine and seconds later there's an
even bigger one
that's the sound of debris raining down
on the car roof
huge mushroom cloud created is captured
by a driver on the other side of the
road
Imagine The Naked fear felt by those in
the middle of all this
this was the north side of the nipro one
of Ukraine's biggest cities
and the attacks here were replicated
across a string of other cities
throughout the country
it is by far the most widespread series
of Russian attacks since the start of
the war hitting 11 key infrastructure
facilities in eight separate regions
quite a record with the war now in its
eighth month
this was the crater caused into nepro by
that double hit in a residential area
there are several apartment blocks
around and it's on a busy bus route
this wave of Russian attacks across the
country has dramatically upped the ante
and suggests far from giving up the
Russian leader has once again doubled
down
the residents trying to piece together
their lives are full of Fury
and they're feeling even more terrified
after this barrage
foreign
but the strikes which rain down in the
heart of the capital city were no doubt
the kremlin's main aim as rumors swirled
about his death the president emerged
house
[Music]
among the Russian leaders attacks one
aimed at kiev's Landmark pedestrian
bridge narrowly missing a walker
mid-route
somehow the bridge remained intact
despite the Russian leader implying this
was in retaliation for the bridge
explosion in Crimea a few days ago
the missiles hit a playground in one of
the capital's main Parks popular among
families with children
and millions saw a young student
narrowly escaped death on her way to
University
many of the capital's residents had
returned in recent months believing
their Capital was safer now
the whistles the sound of another
missile flying in one of 80 across the
country the Russian leaders bent on
making sure they keep flying into
Ukrainian territory and keep wreaking
havoc
difficult to imagine but there could
have been even more destruction more
flattened homes and deaths
yet the Russian leadership's threatening
more attacks
there's no end in sight to this misery
in fact it's just escalated several
notches Alex Crawford Sky News in
Ukraine
join now from KFI velodimir Aria for
Ukrainian MP for the European solidarity
party hello to you thank you for joining
us on the program this morning what can
you tell us about
um the strikes of yesterday and this
morning
oh we have an ongoing alarm rate sorry
now and uh the latest news that one more
power plant
were hit by a Russian missile in Vinita
region so uh there are Russian policy is
ongoing and yesterday uh attack uh we
understand that it was planned in
advance
Putin would like to have represented
like a response uh to the uh explosion
on the Crimea breach but it hasn't been
proven uh who stays behind uh that
attack but for putting it makes no a
reason to find a truth about to use a
reason for escalation in Ukraine uh the
reason for that for me is pretty
understandable uh in one month uh Putin
is going to the meeting of G20 countries
on Bali Island in Indonesia so he would
like to present him not a weak leader
after defeats of Russian army uh in uh
conventional it's a conventional battle
uh grounds but he would like to speak to
the world uh from the position of
strength so that's why he changed the
commander on uh operation against
Ukraine and ah his first day was an
airstrike to scare with the attention to
scary grain of course ukrainians were
not scared but starts more donate to
support uh Ukrainian Army but at the
second uh we understand that next month
we could
be faced to the attention of new offense
from the north side with participation
of Belarus as well as president
lukashenko he yesterday claimed that he
would like to join and support Russia in
uh the uh as as a Ally of uh Belarus uh
and uh the the this means that
Russia Russian plan has clearly seen to
uh divert uh Ukrainian forces from the
offense on East and on the east and
south uh and start to uh to defend much
more North Direction uh Ukrainian
strategist military strategies see what
the Putin wants very clear and we are
really ready to all uh kind of attacks
that we are facing to but at the same
time we need a bit more help uh to beat
out a new wave of Russian aggression
okay
what are you going to do then to
retaliate we've seen these images
um yesterday we know that there have
been more strikes as I was saying in
zapparitzia overnight how will you
retaliate to these attacks sir
well we need uh of course to
strength the Ukrainian air defense
systems and uh yesterday American
President Joe Biden and German
government promised uh to supply Ukraine
with
the modern ones but the at the same time
uh what we are really vitally need now
while uh Ukrainian energy systems are
under operation as well as strikes where
not only to power plants but also for
the case system uh of uh KKK ground
system places
so uh I do believe that in this case
European uh Union uh could be a good
could help us with the supply and uh
electric energy as well as our systems
uh Ukrainian and EU are united to
survive as well as many regions now has
no electricity and
this this situation we don't know how
long it could uh be taken
okay and we know that G7 leaders meeting
today G20 uh Summit uh later on in the
month in Indonesia
what's your message to those world
leaders
yesterday
um uh it was under attack uh the Visa uh
um the Visa uh Consular uh uh office of
German Embassy and uh the German Embassy
where 200 meters from the famous you've
seen the picture uh the uh missile
attack in this city center of uh Kia
so uh I would like to tell that if no
are serious and decisive uh steps uh we
all
will be under attack
so now Ukraine is a playground uh a
battle sorry Battleground for uh the
Democratic world and we understand that
uh without uh permanent and long-term
assistance uh to beat out Russian
aggression and to compel Russia even to
forget uh to uh attack other countries
and neighbors so we cannot survive and
it will be changed the world security
system so we cannot let it make real so
uh to be United and decisive uh
this is the only way what we have to do
it's good to talk to you um do keep safe
thank you for taking the time thank you
in other news a new reporters found that
many people working in the Health
Service are suffering bullying
harassment and unfair treatment a survey
by the British Medical Association
Council found that residents medical
officers are experiencing widespread
poor conditions joining us now is the
Deputy chair of the BMA let's talk to
Emma Brunswick hello to Dr Emma it's
good to see you uh thank you for joining
us I'm very keen to talk about the
report I wonder if I could just briefly
touch on uh first with you though the
health secretary on the show this
morning saying there's no more money for
nurses and if they go on strike for the
first time in 100 years so be it
that's very unfortunate to hear and as
as you may know that Junior doctors and
other doctors in in the BMA are also
looking for an improved pay deal from
this government it's a real great shame
that Therese coffee hasn't taken the
opportunity this morning to emphasize
the value of medical and nursing staff
to the Health Service and chosen to talk
to us we have written to Therese coffee
asking us asking for some discussions
about pay and we haven't had any
responses so it's it's unfortunate to
hear that but we are still open to talks
and and we wish the RCN all solidarity
okay do you feel that um doctors Junior
doctors might also find themselves in a
position where they have no alternative
but to consider strike action
unfortunately yes that's the case so the
junior doctors Committee of the BNA have
already said that if demands for
increased pay aren't met that there will
be a ballot in January so we're already
on our way there for both doctors and of
course for nurses okay talk to me about
the report that you have done with the
doctors Association what were you hoping
to achieve from that
so we've had a number of members come to
us a number of doctors come to us
predominantly from Nigeria but also from
other African countries who have been
recruited by nes Cape medical and a
number of other agencies and employers
and put to work either in the NHS or in
private providers and treated really
appallingly and they've expected to be
treated properly as if they were British
workers as you know as into the
standards that we have here but
unfortunately our survey shows
exploitation lack of support threats
particularly to Visa status poor welfare
and low pay
and unsafe hours lack of rest working
above competency or without support are
really threatening patient safety in
those environments so we are looking for
significant changes to their conditions
including Trade union recognition to
apply to all agency medical staff and
for their contracts to improve up to the
standards of the NHS regardless of who
the direct direct employer is
um okay
um some of the figures that are in the
report are really shocking aren't they
34 of those surveyed reported bullying
and harassment 47 reporting unfair
treatment and 89 report working over a
70-hour week not only damaging for the
health of those that are doing those but
potentially for those that they're
caring for absolutely it's frankly
unsafe the conditions that people are
working in and I think that many
particularly those who are paying for
their health care and privates in the
private sector would be shocked and
surprised by the conditions under which
their medical team are working
and there are plenty of doctors under
this survey who told us that they were
working a whole week on 168 hours with
minimal rest breaks during the night
which might be disturbed
and so so 70 hours is was really almost
at the low end for many of these people
and and the bullying is I mean quite
horrific I won't repeat some of the
racist things that people have reported
to us and but I was surprised that they
would they would come to such
such harassment in the UK
so who's bullying whom
so it's a mixture so the doctors who are
working for these companies are often
from Nigeria or other similar Nations
and they're facing bullying both from
their employer the agency but also from
their colleagues who are working
alongside them in the health system and
and it's quite difficult to challenge
that because if they challenge that the
agency or their employer is both their
employer their GMC responsible officer
their visa status holder that sometimes
they're landlord so raising concerns
often leaves you a position of being
very trapped and it's quite difficult
for people to get out of those
situations
um
one wonders who those people can turn to
absolutely and I mean we're we're
encouraging those people to turn to Wars
as their Trade union we're here to help
we have a contract checking service
we're trying to eliminate really
duplicitous contracts that don't stand
up to a moment scrutiny we're offering
to support to International Medical
graduates who are new to the country
we're lobbying their employers for
improvements to paying conditions
and we're hoping that we can tackle some
of the problems with them at work and
for a range of these organizations which
really shouldn't be allowed to get away
with this any longer
okay good to talk to you um thanks very
much indeed for taking the time to join
us much appreciated thank you no worries
thank you so much
quick look at the weather
anticipation is rising and so is the
atmosphere are you ready
the weapon sponsored by Qatar Airways
mostly fine today rain moving into the
West later marks a change to more
unsettled conditions
the weather sponsored by Qatar Airways
well A lot's happened since seven
o'clock this morning let me tell you
including the fact that nurses have said
that they are considering strike for the
first time in more than a hundred years
we put that to the health secretary and
she said there will be no more pay we
put that to a representative for the
British Medical Association just now and
she said Junior doctors are also
thinking about voting for strike action
at the start of the new year and she was
saddened at the news from the Deputy
Prime Minister the Deputy Prime Minister
also telling us that the economy is on
track looking good and words to that
effect despite the ifs saying there's a
60 billion pound black hole in your
figures and you need to sort it out as a
matter of some urgency Bank of England
also reacting to that this morning and
we'll be telling you more about what
they have had to say in just a few
moments time also bringing you pictures
of Larry the cat who was looking for a
bit of a spout as well with a fox on
number 10. what on Earth was all all
that about
stay tuned and find out
[Music]